so that is something that I think Nike L
is going to have to really watch out for
not just when it's on offense but also
the assists yes absolutely and this is
really impactful and Wawa knows how to
use it like an expert of course it hits
both sides as well so just because you
sell over it a lot of times players will
feel safe in situations like that right
weather so offer an assist maybe those
super - back in but a force base Goku
shuts it down on both sides so you got
to be very careful when combatting up
against wall want any base multiplayer
everybody's handling business here you
guys didn't get to see it but not yell
like a true professional make sure to
disconnect all Bluetooth devices before
getting into the match really eSports
here
all right I think it's just because of
how tall nikhil is he looks so much
bigger right now then did you see the
fist bump
oh is it it looked like Nagios hands
like ten times the size of wah wah what
was a growing boy man a young player
okay I think maybe I have to change the
song I believe so it all right back to
the care just like we're ready to get
back into the match afterwards
I forgot how old wah-wah actually is but
I know who is it in his teens even if
it's a later on like 18 19 I believe I
could be making that would take a stool
into the Kai's I love land of the car
there's there's so much possibility in
this matchup
I think her dramatic finished with Kid
Buu and Goku moving on along as a team I
see right yeah your body finishes are
the best parts of the game but we just
don't get to see them that often
yeah it's like some really like try hard
stuff like if you can't personally pull
it off right yeah
it'd be exciting though I relish the day
indeed but we are going into and
everyone top 32 let's go winners side we
got Wawa representing France up against
Knockhill representing you and Sophie
and France give it up for Wawa has
really bursted on to the Dragonball
Fighters seeing has been one of the most
inspiring incredible players that we've
had so we'll see if not you have to make
a statement here media raw tigers to go
pro I'm not sure if that's what he was
looking for he has turned me alive leave
the simple that off that's it
oh and wala find the opening here
one thing we saw earlier when while
we're playing with just the constant
consistency with via sits and extending
on the dragon your opponent into the
corner and the back ball - yeah while
while always testing a bullet his
opponents early with the basketball
while we saw it not yo walk forward a
little bit there by recognizing super -
in time Venus's does get the guard
cancel out without too much of a
punishment and you smashed up in the air
there to detect with the jump medium on
block but he's back with the opening
here you can ease leg loops in the
corner I love it cuz wall just preys on
your human habits right he doesn't
actually get high enough to do like any
calling mix-up or anything like that
please shows you the animation did not
want to deal with any that catches it
with a delayed garden or vanish in the
air there from sparking yeah oh wait so
would it be vegan off me he's a TAS mark
of his life all blue like leave I just
think of the kill it's not gonna matter
here and he will upon his mismatch
knocked out the end oh yeah it's dragon
rush smash level one
powered up all the way through the level
for even good stuff
Trump and them down to the ground
they're picking them up already down a
character here both players on sparking
ball goes into the lab and just
practices fast balls
read the key glass perfectly
not yell now applying the pressure on
the corner here where all along with
that base Goku just blocking it out oh
come on
Oh super - Jokke oh what's that one all
right back into it
gonna keep it safe there okay yep the
gg-go Lewis is hitting the GAR cancer so
you get some wonderful Punisher
great defense here from Matt y'all
okay good reflect there all right going
in trying to Oh get the jump medium does
not confirm up a bit yeah tried to - up
in what the five mile afterwards and
rather than going to the five out all
right great defense here from wah-wah
liebe tried through like altering the
timing on the double overhead finally
gets the head
yeah he just like gave up there for a
second all right we've got extensions
here we drove me said we talked about
all right and I feel like the treat as a
publish the same when it comes to his
own confidence level so he is going
through the obstacle via combos
[Music]
wouldn't there by the gg-go to assist
but it's not gonna be enough until great
kept therefore Wawa yeah can we go jump
and follow up and veggies ego chrysalis
and so we're saying going through been
locked out for so long from life's ants
on fly settings oh my goodness the
patients right now from this man how
long can wallow hold on in the corner
reflective it is right back to blocking
sharing a message with this oh my gosh
how long will we go for taking the
dragonball this is a young man I told
you finally get the empty long yeah
right off that light incredible blocks
mental damage has to have been done even
despite getting the kill a knock your
side who could boss that top that's the
box below
Oh Eddie just gets right back into it
with the two three six the corners will
go forward this is a change of pace for
sure right now but we have Bullock
baby out yeah this is the main chicken
this is one you put up on the map with
Jason I really like the way not just the
plane and so far huh
Oh almost got the cross up there all
right just keep it nice and basic at
this point right 6m into the goal
harnesses can extend with the power pole
get them all the way to the corner here
dragon rush and not gonna be able to
take the first game over wall wall what
it changed momentum there - it looked
things were looking very grim almost yes
yeah he managed to just come back from
that I mean it really felt like Wawa was
just sending a message with the blocking
at that point right it was just like you
know anything you throw at me I'm gonna
end up blocking and it was looking like
a lot of mental damage is gonna be
incurred but no knock yell bouncing back
the thing that was crazy to me is even
every dragon rush was tech yeah
any option he went for he blocked and
Zelos you take dragon rushes he blocked
multiple overheads I mean the kids
defense is unreal however not Yale did
find enough openings to take the first
game and as I mentioned he's
underperformed at these Dragon Ball Tour
events but a big win over Wawa would be
an incredible statement to make right
now and it's something that Nakia has
been working on relentlessly right
tirelessly his mental composure his
mental strength showed in that last game
it almost looks like father and son
this matter if you've never met knocking
on real life I beg he's taller than you
yeah like goku and gohan right now yeah
voilá though doesn't look too shaken
either no Walla Walla really is
strategic at keeping his composure I
feel yeah so let's go into a safe or not
[Music]
the stocks when we go fight all right
therefore the function himself of all
why does not want to take any more
blocks trips out here bring food not
knows marigold pizza mark
this is a hole on snap that's half right
now is great for not do as well because
he wasted all that smart in time wall
while use the sparking and it's not even
gonna save a character Oh golly drop it
this is spelled room all the wrong is
based on real life but another cancel to
the to age you've been looking for them
rush here this is gonna be a dead part
off the flow fat to sound like that and
not you know commanding lead base Goku
burying a city life left
lap you know doesn't have a scratch of
dead and why
Bardock like that that's gonna hurt I
don't know I don't know if I approve the
switch right now you know I feel like
this adult go on is just fine yeah
absolutely
Bardock not doing a thing thing let's
come around okay heavy legs going in the
GT Goku you are locked out there sir
with this mascara girl would go hon
Louis is needed Auto combo City and a
side switch no yes sorry dad alright
heavy legs out just to buy some time
there ball out to our lockdown goes for
the low and ethnic Luis is the great
equalizer I'd no matter how good your
blocks are it's real tough to get it
done Calathes finally find a successful
counter vote this might be the momentum
switch that wallet needs and then are we
gonna see a level three from GT
much damage at the table as possible
yeah because he's side switch with base
boat
he's gonna side some deafness level 3
again and happen in the corner smart
stuff for all
sparking blocks again all right you're
locked down here while defeat bets again
nobody helps would have blocked out I
feel oh but he finally gets opened up
here delayed the five in just long
enough to catch wall while moving scream
and get the full health get boo in
[Music]
to the dragon rush Nakia yeah this is
total change of pace here nap yell very
dominant in this game back prepared to
the last was a little bit more even
sided I feel throughout most of it this
is very very strong here when I do clash
with the super dashes but he's gonna be
big chillin here he's got the goal
harnesses yeah I like that calling it
while he jumps over and running get a
little bit damaging where he can
along the other side at Nike updates it
little drop a character the second game